how does a cinema camera that's arguably
one of the best cameras in the world
compared to an iphone whoa
we went out of focus right away okay
little animals freaking out ooh
yeah yeah
nothing really makes me happier than
working with a good camera a camera that
can capture the world accurately and
beautifully take what your eyes see and
elevate it somehow that's one of the
best things out there at least for me in
my left hand here i have an iphone x i
just got it yesterday i've taken like
one picture with it
my right hand i'm holding an epic w from
red i just got this few weeks ago shot
one video with it this is a hollywood
cinema camera it is using the most
cutting edge in sensor technology that
red has their helium sensor this is a
cutting edge phone is a flagship device
from apple the biggest phone
manufacturer in the world i'm curious
how does a cinema camera that's arguably
one of the best cameras in the world
compared to an iphone that's arguably
one of the best phones in the world with
one of the best cameras can you even
tell the difference i'm going to run
through a series of tests that i think
define what makes a good camera what
makes a good image so what are the
qualities of a good camera there's a
whole range of things so we're going to
be testing a bunch of different things
here starting off with resolution
resolution is how many pixels your image
has the more pixels the more detail you
can resolve also if your image is really
high resolution you can actually crop
into it zoom into it without noticing
any loss in detail it's very very useful
for a filmmaker when they have to
reframe and recompose their shots the
helium sensor is an 8k sensor meaning
horizontally there's 8000 pixels in your
image that's a ton of pixels the iphone
tops out at 4k horizontally there's 4000
pixels in image still a ton of pixels
set the camera here we're going to zoom
in on some details down the street on
the computer uh apparently this segment
is brought to you by dhl
i wonder how far we can zoom in
just a video clip of the street guys
pretty crazy
next up we're going to test dynamic
range dynamic range is the range in
light that your camera can capture
before it completely clips out in the
white or descends into noise in the
shadows the range between those two
points the wider it is the wider your
dynamic range and generally speaking the
wider your dynamic range the more
forgiving your camera is and more
painterly your images look now the way
we're going to do this i'm going to have
bridger here stand in the doorway of
this hallway where it's kind of dark i'm
going to expose for his face and it's
bright daylight behind him we're going
to see if the camera can capture that it
might be blown out white we might have
all the color in detail we'll see who
doesn't love a good slow motion shot
everybody loves a good slow motion shot
the thing is when you're doing slow
motion on a camera your frame rate is
much much higher your camera is
processing frames a lot faster and it's
a lot more data for the system to handle
so shortcuts have to be taken so we're
going to see what kind of shortcuts have
been taken on the iphone you do 240
frames per second versus shortcuts on
the red let you do 240 frames per second
on that and is there any visual
difference which one looks better we
have a bunch of fireworks left over from
360 wizard video so we're gonna use them
[Music]
action
good
got it
hello there it's time to test the low
light capabilities of these cameras but
before we go into this test i want to
just briefly talk about some of the tech
here this camera probably has noise
removal built into it whereas this
camera is capturing raw data and saving
that raw data for you to then manipulate
and post so the way they're capturing
low light is going to be a little bit
different this is going to have some
computer health happening whereas this
one you would do that later on and post
on the computer so we're in a pretty
dark room it's only lit by two lights
are at like half brightness over there
and honestly the technicalities of how
much light is in this room doesn't
really matter so we're just comparing
the cameras so i'm gonna get a shot of
bridger sitting on the couch doesn't
look too bad on the screen i'm not gonna
lie so now we're going to do a codec
test a codec is how your camera is
translating those photons hitting that
sensor and giving off electrical signals
into an image it needs to store all that
data somehow it needs to translate that
data into a presentable image that you
can then work with different codecs such
different qualities some of you have a
lot of compression which is to say that
you can make a very small file size just
a couple megabytes of a very complicated
image that comes with the trade-off
parts of your image get thrown away
because the codec has to assume which
elements of data you want and which ones
you don't some other codecs like the one
on this red camera will capture much
more data and much more information but
the file sizes are a lot bigger now the
way i like to do this is to stress test
the codec by making each new frame new
data that has to be written because a
codec will compress your footage by
looking at your frames and figuring out
what doesn't change from frame to frame
and by just telling your computer or
your phone or whatever your device is
that's doing the decoding saying oh this
section of the background doesn't change
between the frames then it doesn't have
to provide new data for that part of the
frame and it makes your file size
smaller but if every frame is new then
it has to rewrite each frame and if
there's a data limit on that compression
then it's going to get blurry and blocky
and it's not going to look very good so
the way i like to do this to go outside
where it's bright raise the shutter
speed really high so there's no motion
blur and just wiggle the camera really
fast and that makes each frame new
coming up we're going to compare the
footage that we just shot and see if you
really could shoot a movie on your
iphone
science
keeping things not not distracting
talking about these animojis what's the
story behind the animojis it's motion
capture the phone is using an infrared
camera to pick up my facial features in
3d and apply it to a little animated
emoji everyone's got facial motion
capture in their pocket right now and
it's too good of an opportunity to pass
up and not make a hilarious video with
little animals freaking out yeah yeah
yeah yeah
how are you liking your iphone x so far
they're great all the hype is real it's
fast enough to run the latest operating
system of apple which is uh exactly why
you buy a new phone they keep making the
operating system harder and harder to
run so you have to buy a better and
better phone to run it i haven't taken
an actual picture with it yet
your first picture i like ice lights
things like that whoa it just uses the
infrared camera to isolate the
environment a little bit look at that
just me oh god that kind of looks like
garbage actually yeah we're trying to
figure out how to
what to do for our animoji video people
as animals as people
you know people with an animal head
pretending they're people but with
animal habits you go out to eat with
friends and you all meet up at the cafe
and everyone's like
eating dog food just on the floor
all right so
it's time to look at the footage prepare
these shots i brought in a guest witness
everybody meets sam
hi my name's sam i am 31 years old and i
like to
uh play guitar and deep dish pepperoni
pizza
so we're gonna do a compression test
here so this is the red as i whip that
camera around really fast left and right
back and forth notice that you can look
at the sign you can still see all the
details a little like cross hatching in
the sign none of that's getting lost and
all the detail in the wall the ground
the marker paths perhaps zoomed in like
the three hundo wow look at all that
detail there's all the detail like no
it's being like you can see every single
line on that sign it's not breaking down
at all i do not see a single artifact or
any squares or whatever so here we are
with the iphone x static looks great
plenty of detail in the shot i can see
all the cross hatching on the side
and away we go whoa we went out of focus
right away okay go back to like the
second frame ground actually looks
pretty good i'm seeing some blurriness
and blocking on the edge of the wall
there okay there we go we snapped onto
the sign for a second here it's pretty
much just a static shot but notice all
the detail on the sign all those cross
hatching those little like squares on it
completely gone even though this frame
doesn't have any blurring like any
motion blur it's just a static frame all
the fine detail is completely gone
because the phone has a data limit as to
how much detail it can put down for each
frame but here's another great example
coming in getting slower getting slower
and as i slow down it starts to be able
to reuse data from each frame so here
the sign is white can't see any detail
go a frame further it's starting to
crisp it up a little bit and go frame
further and now you can see all the
cross hatching on it again but that
means that if you're getting a really
high action shot like let's say you're
filming confetti that means that as a
confetti starts moving and your frame
gets all crazy and each new frame needs
to be new data it's going to start to
get blurry and you're not going to get
anywhere near that 4k resolution that
you've been promised all right let's
take a look at dynamic range here so
here's bridger hanging out giving us a
wave and the camera is currently exposed
for his face here and the background is
pretty bright let's take a look at how
much data we actually have in the
background there i'm just going to pull
down the iso hold on the exposure here
all right so looking at this background
here we can see that the clouds are
clipped a little bit there's a part
where just is a flat white that can turn
into a grape but there's plenty of blue
in that sky plenty of data there i can
see the entire building behind him so
all that is being captured and using
color grading you could pull that in
work with it but this is how it looks
when i captured it all right let's take
a look at the iphone oh god that's
pretty gnarly now it's worth noting
there's differences in saturation here
the iphone is handling the image and
processing it a little bit differently
all right so flipping back and forth
between them i see one noticeable
difference outside of the color ignoring
the color shift for a second it looks
like a white cloud has appeared right
above the building we flip back to the
other frame there is no white cloud
there that is not a white cloud it is
simply the sensor clipping out it's
because the sky has gotten so bright
there that any sort of signal that the
sensor on the phone is getting is just
pure clipped out at full signal which
gets interpreted as white whereas in the
red there's still blue sky there shadow
wise they're capturing about the same
amount of detail but in the highlights
clearly there's more data being captured
on the red beyond that highlight
retention though it doesn't look that
bad it's capturing a lot of good color
in the background and bridger himself
looks pretty well exposed and has a lot
of good detail in him all right
resolution i expect this to not be a
contest i'm going to take this i'm going
to blow it up all right i'm going to get
real zoomed in here
i would say i would say this is a little
unfair it's like right now the iphone
appears to have just a little more
detail but that's probably due to
sharpening now i would say that if you
kind of made red footage a little more
contrasty and sharpened it i can do that
right now so now we flip back and forth
not quite perfectly lined up at first
glance they actually seem pretty close
like looking at the front of the car
here compared to here it looks almost
identical but i start to see some
differences look at the bricks on this
peach colored building on the red i can
see every single line of bricks on the
phone it's a mush same with the road
it's all just kind of mush here as the
compression kind of takes out the detail
that doesn't think you're going to see
on the red i can see all the pebbles in
the rocks and granted we're super zoomed
in so it's kind of fuzzy but all that
detail is still there really not as big
of a difference as i would have expected
and perceptively like once you zoom out
a little bit probably can't really tell
the difference too much between the two
but i can read stop on the stop sign in
the red and i can't read it on the phone
there i think that's the best example
right there yeah all right slow motion
time i predict that these are gonna look
very similar all right so here we are
away some slow motion from the iphone
bouncers
wow this is 240 frames per second that's
pretty slow there's a bit of a shimmer
to the image you can see it here like on
the pebbles here on the ground see they
kind of shift and shimmer like they pop
up and down by a pixel at a time um you
can see it in the power lines too see
how they kind of shift and shimmer there
a little bit aliasing iphone can't read
all pixels off that sensor at 240 frames
per second it's skipping pixels and what
you get with that is you get a bit of
aliasing in moire i don't know is it
more
you get this flickering effect all right
here's the red oh yes look how much
softer and gentler this image looks
so crisp and so high quality that guy is
slow motion to look good that guy's a
little nervous that you guys are doing
camera tests but look how much better
this looks look at the insane yeah the
insane amount of dynamic range that
we're still getting here with like the
flame the fire and all that stuff like
obviously it's higher on the red but i'm
pretty sure they're sacrificing a little
bit of that dynamic range to get more
frames in there there's no shimmer if i
go back and forth in frames there's no
shimmer on the ground i do actually see
heat ripples which is actually another
testament to the codec those heat
ripples will be lost because the
movement would be so small that it would
get disregarded when being compressed on
the iphone yeah but once again this
phone's doing 240 frames per second it's
pretty dang good
test number two the test that matters
this is a test that unites kingdoms and
makes them fall apart that's the alien
signal we received
[Laughter]
same thing on the red looks like i'm
actually a little out of focus on you so
interesting thing here is because i'm so
cropped in on the sensor on the red it's
hard to pull focus where it's a lot
easier to pull focus on the phone so in
a way when it comes to slow motion both
these cameras are actually doing a
pretty decent job of it and the iphone
has its strengths here like it's a
little bit easier to use it's a little
bit wider angle yeah sure the image gets
a little chunky but the red image is a
little chunky too in its own way so nico
would any of these advantages lead you
to use an iphone instead of a red on a
film set no but i probably actually
wouldn't use either of these cameras for
doing 240 frames per second i'd actually
probably go back to our dragon why the
dragon the dragon when you crop into 2k
to do slow motion doesn't crop in on the
sensor as far all right finally low
light in the past reds actually haven't
had very good low light sensitivity the
helium is the first red sensor to
actually have some oomph in that realm
of low light so here we are at 6400 iso
bridger relaxing and there is some grain
that's this whole point here is to push
the camera to the point of starting to
get some grain it doesn't look too bad
for how dark the room was
and here's the iphone
roughly same brightness receptacle but
once again compared to old iphones much
better and it was actually really dark
but i'm actually pretty impressed with
the red here that looks pretty dang good
for being low light i'm looking at the
edge of the couch here in the wall this
is the red i'm gonna do the same thing
here it's kind of same spot here
catching the wall so the grain size like
the grain is there on the red it's
definitely present then here's the grain
on the iphone coming up here
it's a little more pronounced on the
iphone and when you have the red file at
8 000 pixels horizontal that noise that
grain becomes very fine and becomes much
less perceptible that's where resolution
has a bit of an advantage for low light
the red is definitely utilizing that
advantage here to give us a cleaner low
light frame it looks pretty dang good
i'm not gonna lie i know it's not a
cinema camera it looks freaking great
yeah
when i'm shooting videos by phone i
don't really want to have to color grade
it and color correct it and do all that
kind of stuff overall the cinema camera
obviously still has its perks cinema
cameras have obviously gotten better and
better to the point now where they have
much more dynamic range and much more
resolution than film and these cameras
built into our phones are starting to
approach that point i would say the
iphone x is better than every camera i
used up until
2011. three years four years who knows
maybe in that short amount of time we'll
have phones that capture video quality
at the same quality as
our very first scarlet
we'll see
hey guys just a little something off
topic from the video here in another
video i showed off my finished sellers a
catan set that i 3d printed and i asked
everybody what i should use to spray it
to protect the paint because all the
other matte finishes i tried were too
shiny and everybody recommended test
doors dull coat and it worked out great
i just want to thank you guys for
helping me out suggesting what i should
use it worked like a charm my catonset
is truly finished with your help
[Music]
you